Sophia, I'm saying this with love.
I'm not coming at you. I'm.
I'm trying to come alongside you
because I looked at your profile and now you're 23.
I'm not trying to be rude or disrespectful to you in the fucking least.
Like, I need you to understand that part.
There is nothing but love.
Like if you were my daughter.
Because at 23,
I didn't know this at the time,
and I suspect that maybe you don't know this either.
Your brain, mama,
is not fully developed.
You're not even the complete and total person that you're gonna be
to present to this world. See what I'm saying?
Your brain is still fully forming.
And I'm only saying it like that for you to understand the gravity,
not because you're stupid,
not because I'm talking down to you like the shit.
Like, weighs on me to be like, wow,
we make such life long decisions
without literally without all the tools to make them.
So I understand that at 23,
you believe in your chest that if you just love yourself,
you're gonna find a man that loves you on that same level.
And at that point, now,
you can be completely vulnerable
and give him full authority over your life
by purposely rejecting all opportunities to have any.
Any choice for yourself.
But I need you to understand,
at 41, almost 42,
you gotta understand the perspective that I can see this from.
Because I was 23, I Held those beliefs,
I made those decisions,
and I'm living proof that it backfires.
And I'm not the only one
I'm happy for.
I don't give a fuck that dudes online are gonna make a joke about me.
What I care about is women like you.
That learn before it's too late.
That it's a life of service to another person.
Is not a life of fulfillment.